I believe ultimately cart estimators
current says you should really only use
a car if you can't get where you're
going on foot or by bicycle but some
cars are so much fun to drive that you
can't resist the temptation like the
Audi rs3 and it's just how to make these
hot soy de it's the Audi is trying to
deer come gets in under Yuba are better
than desi won the first Audi rs3 came
out in 2011 Audi manufactured this 250
kilowatt compact for a year but then it
disappeared from the showrooms the
second generation came in 2015 and now
it has been improved the Audi rs3 is
powered by a five cylinder in-line
engine says Montes newly developed it's
noticeably more powerful than its
predecessor for this for gals
the new engines cubic capacity is still
just two and a half liters but now it
produces 294 kilowatts 24 kilowatts more
than the previous generation
[Music]
but for RS 3 enthusiasts the sound is
just as important as the power the sound
does s modest explains that the rs3
sound derives from a special ignition
sequence an alternation between adjacent
and distant cylinders firing at the same
time it's most evident when you shift
from the standard D Drive program to s
and Montes thinks it sounds great cleans
my station standard equipment in the RS
3 includes a 7-speed dual-clutch
transmission and electronically
controlled all-wheel drive which ensures
neutral handling and makes the car easy
to control even in extreme situations
so that's lift in addition to the odrs 3
sport back there is now another body
variant a sedan Motta's ash Stephan
Winkelmann
head of the audi sport division y boom
the ethic in that first generation rs3
was limited to a sport packs as vinca
model it was very successful but mostly
in Europe this time out he wants to
appeal to the whole world so it's added
a sedan with an eye to the North
American and Asian markets he predicts a
sport back to sedan sales ratio of 60 to
40 so they see Hudson gleaming black
aerodynamic components and back in front
a gleaming honeycomb single frame
radiator grille and big air intakes both
variants of the rs3 seemed to scream
racetrack even when part
[Music]
optional and the interior are the
red-rimmed air vents colored stitching
on the steering wheel and gearshift knob
and napa leather sport seats
the sedan drives pretty much like the
sport back both accelerate equally fast
the top speed of each can be raised from
250 to 280 kilometers an hour if desired
[Applause]
the end of the clematis is due to their
different body shapes the sedan weighs
five kilos less than the Sportback and
its weight is differently distributed as
a result the sedan is even more agile
than the already very sporty sport back
as long as you're driving on public
roads rather than a racetrack these
differences will seldom make a
difference
[Music]
Emily I notice as choosing an Audi rs3
is step number one step two is deciding
between the sedan and the sport back the
sport backs trunk is easier to load so
it's a bit more practical but montes
thinks the rs3 sedan is really chic so
he choose it Xia Xia shake on the swing
goody here global Hisoka avoid initial
practices my novel of the era styling
mousse in the fan the updated rs3 sport
back and the new rs3 sedan will arrive
in car showrooms starting in August
until then customers have time to
consider which version best suits their
needs and desires
you
[Music]